oh yeah Oh cut this clapping welcome
everyone we're very excited we're down
here in San Diego for a comic-con
even though comic-con hasn't started yet
we are gonna start our first show
tomorrow but today we are very excited
to welcome to San Diego Padres Eric
Johnson and Robbie early yeah I love it
you can't clap he's holding
I'd say we're gonna play a little bit of
Mario Kart and we're here to answer all
your questions these guys are only here
though till 11:30 so we only get them
for a little while then we're gonna have
a fun special guest stop by after that
so we were talking a little bit before
we did one practice game but you guys
haven't really played a lot of video
games not the gamers no no no you guys
actually play real games you try to you
I love it all right so hit a there we go
there we go all right I'm gonna go I'm
going wuji perfect I'm doing a different
bike I don't know what any of this means
on wheels yeah this is like a pirate but
exactly exactly
Jr's 14 dude you don't have to come to
comic-con you can watch our show and
it's just like being comic-con I'm going
flying squirrel because that's my spirit
animal it's a flying squirrel I see that
in you sure I know you know what I gotta
say this is my favorite my favorite
comic-con snack and everyone thinks it's
flaming hot cheetos it's just normal
cheetos lady hot cheetos can suck it
dudes I have a shirt with like a pocket
like this except it's fried chicken and
waffles
do you guys for training have to be like
on certain diets those pants are
form-fitting Oh frantic mode no thank
you
nope nope I didn't know what is frantic
mode keeps going back to frantic it
wants frantic well play frantic next all
right we just for a warm-up Ron we
played Mario Kart Stadium I think we get
a little weird you want to go what do
you think waterpark yes nice it's
summertime
saying it's hot down here in the Diego
that's what I call it because it's
cooler than San Diego Suicide Squad hype
yes we're having Suicide Squad on what
day Beth is Suicide Squad gonna be here
on Saturday for exactly are you guys now
you guys comic book guys at all or
superhero guys well I want to I saw the
trailer for a Suicide Squad don't see
that it looks tight right it looks great
here I mean I guess I've seen all like
the Marvel movies I think in the extent
I think you have to like you're like
everyone is like 500 as an American you
have to all right so yeah memory goes
are you in the pirate ship - I've got a
trap got a three-wheeler I do the
handling on this oh yeah baby I don't
know where to go up the stairs are you
guys car guys do you guys have sweet
whips as the kids say by the way if I
say whip again you're allowed to punch
now that's a rule dude it's second wait
what are you wait Eric are you down
there
bottom screen oh nice before I Robbie's
up top
Eric's on the bottle have you been
watching my stream long time I have
actually I was like dude I'm in first
and then I was like oh I'm in seventh
oh god I'm perfect recently what does
that mean exactly so we just signed a
bunch of guys
it's like pretty cool it's just like
bringing in like the next wave look yeah
I'm sorry agent central yeah where's
awesome taking over the world
Padres that's great is it weird and like
like Eric we were saying before you
played for the White Sox and I are the
Padres yeah
is it how weird is it to switch teams I
mean do it I mean I would guess that
you're probably welcome to the open arms
onto a new team but it's kind of like
making you friends at a new school right
yeah for sure it's definitely that it's
a whole just staff older team a bunch of
guys I I know I know a few guys from
just you know playing in college and
yeah just through the ranks but I yeah
I've always been a white sock and then
coming with Padre has been awesome
that's great the weather way better down
here in Chicago unless you video can't
be nuts Diego that's what you said right
Diego yeah down here in the deep the
sweet B that's right
III grew up it's a Tigers fan sorry I
know exactly and it's hilarious when
they you know because they got a new
stadium a little while ago Comerica Park
yeah when they built it this is a true
story by the way they didn't account
they put too much like cement and the
whole thing so no one's cell phone
worked really so they couldn't broadcast
the first game but they didn't have like
hard cabling so yeah the frantically
like isn't that great it was like oh
Detroit
oh you guys crack me up my people like
people they're good though yeah yeah out
there now which is good oh damn yeah I
came in last come on yeah I do
you know I - I was letting you guys I
was kind of we're gonna play for money
here - yeah just kind of hustle
exactly
who's winning rebuy nature I think Erik
won Robbie came on Rob oh brother
Oh rot wait who's - again I'm Wario
you're on the bottom here's the bottom
Robbie can second
feels like exactly so yeah so you guys
are rehabbing right now no you guys are
pictures rehabbing them would it take us
through a day like what it what does
that mean like what is a typical day for
you guys are you happy my phone the
teams here show up for the field and
just get your like treatment in and
physical therapy and then kind of go
through your workouts and cardio stuff
and go through maybe another set of plug
in my case like treatment or physical
therapy this is there what is that just
like throwing a bounce ball or something
or down it's just like trying to get my
arm to move oh okay yeah you pitched
left right yeah but you bat right yep
inches now how did I know it's I got no
it's man I come prepared I come prepared
how does how how did that come one in
the other no idea it's just feel it just
feels good yes like this maybe I play
there like swing right but then play
golf left and then right with both hands
yeah do you wait what are you right with
your left foot
dude yeah your brain did you grow up
here like power lines you're like it
you're much like radiation yeah really
good shittiest x-men you're probably
mutant power if you can kind of do so
it's both sides man it's terrible oh my
god what we do if you guys can assume
that power for real what would it be
besides being able to do everything on
one side of your body
professional athletes you guys kind of
already are superheroes you're the
closest thing and that's to I would say
that's true
I mean you couldn't pull off a shirt
this dumb but I think pretty much
anything else yeah best part is you
can't tell at home it actually smells
like Cheetos also yeah scratch and sniff
and it's itchy so it's I would say
scratchy and smooth
yeah exactly like shake and bake yeah
exactly yeah it's a crappier version of
shakin baby
[Music]
you guys have any secret handshakes or
anything that you guys work on those are
the secret oh see well played and tried
to trick you
I think if I was a pitcher - speaking of
actually secrets you guys have see which
one oh man I'm not I'm not gonna look at
my notes
who's got the oh I think Robbie's got
the good curveball right ah there we go
do you guys name your pitches secretly
in your head oh like oh man I'm gonna
throw the the the ice dagger is that
really nice dagger man I would totally
get super into it I think make it as
dumb as possible
since you guys are rehab you got a lot
of time to think coming up with any you
guys it's your team do pranks or
anything like that you guys pick
prankers on the old Padres pretty loyal
to each other pretty finely around these
parts I like that I like that so
friendly it's the vibe down here in the
D it's pretty it's pretty chillax the
ice one the worst hey what I think if I
had a spirit animal it would be a
penguin thought you were flying the
world
well flying squirrel is what I what I
tell people I am because it's cool put
in my heart I'm a flightless bird you
know who like lives in the cold
yeah like out there in the cold man
again I gotta pay more attention this
game in see you guys naturally
competitive fellas
alright no more
I'm not gonna take it easy on you guys
I'm not gonna take flying squirrels away
no diaper talk no Cheetos talk the plan
sherbert land because that's what you
said you didn't want to play all right
yeah dirty you guys talking on it I
really yeah yes a good about yeah not
like cars like just regular verbage
honest like yeah it's kinda just a part
of just how you communicate with people
let's see here where's the oldest
sherbert land land I'm like terribly
that talking I'm like your mom is a
nice lady you know you just kind of say
it and they're like oh thank you yeah
it's like wait a second you look very
good in that shirt they're like what
yeah it was that so okay yeah this
controller is what I like to call
this is terrible it's like playing with
a dinner plate or an iPad thing
that's nice this is yeah this is this is
what happens if you want to come in last
use this controller also pick this
terrible bike this thing sucks
you know now I read that uh the guy who
created Mario is so valuable to Nintendo
that he's not allowed to ride his bike
to work it's too dangerous
now like a motorcycle like a bicycle you
don't want to do that you see the belt
like new stuff ah that's a good question
I don't know there's that pokemons go
thing if you guys played that it off
dude I was gonna ask you how long until
you guys do a show I mean I've been
playing it as soon as Conan has a spare
moment I think we're gonna do some
Pokemon go stuff we I had lunch with
Conan yesterday and I caught a Pokemon
go on his face it was awesome how does
that work it's weird it's like it uses
your phone it tells where you are
through like Google Maps right uh uh and
and then like get out of your hooking on
just randomly Pablo I'm not a Pokemon
fan wait are you only asking me
questions so I'm gonna come in last
probably and then when you're near when
it opens your camera off it so that you
kind of see it kind of in the real world
almost it says are easy it's like you're
looking through the screen of your yeah
it's really weird I saw a video on
YouTube where a guy this is not a joke a
guy his wife is giving birth and he was
like catching pokémon good
Oh what's up man
didn't some guy like walk out yeah yes
kid got hit by a car watch were you
going kids although I will say maybe
it's like you know look natural
selection works anymore but like the
Darwin Awards you know when people like
oh don't fall in the old pit dude you're
not hitting any penguins
all right oh man dude early
[Music]
man oh hell here we go here we go
coming up this isn't like this isn't the
original one no I think they kind of
redid it why are you making excuses now
for not doing as well
but this isn't like like this is a pixel
for pixel right there realize yeah this
uses like mad I can't have Eric beat me
oh no Laurie I'm in the powder the
powder I'm underwater it's so cool oh
that's three in a row you effort - yeah
slightly killer over here is a see what
yeah just quiet and they're just killing
it just killing it my god know if you
guys are just joining us we were playing
Mario Kart today we're down at San Diego
comic-con or Conan Con as we like to
call it with a couple great San Diego
Padres Eric Johnson and Robbie erlin Hey
look we collected twenty hundred coins I
don't know what that means you know
what's the point of coins in the race I
have no idea
I know I should I should know more about
this game I don't what can I say I need
a different person screw that man yeah
hey today I'm going you know what I'm
going light and I'm going fast I'm going
baby Mario I'm going the smallest bike
they got I need to be more literal your
bodies from them I need mean well back
out okay are you gonna go to peach
hey gray moon yes we are working on
Pokemon go thing for the show it'd be
awesome
Oh Thank You bees music we got a we got
a great wallpaper that's right run it
down Comic Con Thank You Daegu moss
forgive us our art director we got a new
umbrella you couldn't get you thought
you couldn't get more girly in the
dandelion you're wrong now we've got a
little uh this is I'm like The
Terminator likely for Mario oh yeah dude
evil t1000 Mario need new vehicle
exactly yeah jr. its I think it's the
normal controller I'm blaming it on this
thing and also the fact that I'm
terrible at this
are you following that for you exactly
it's way too fast waited the Scottie
guys I didn't even know what that means
this is again I YouTube his bananas I'm
sorry YouTube you guys are all crazy
twitch those yeah now it's just exactly
Portugal they're all just yelling among
themselves Portugal what is the love
exactly
Kony Khan baby all right we're going
fast jets 200 CCS I work best with a lot
of speed I read all right let's get a
little that's cool cuckoo let's get a
little crazy I start drifting oh you
want some drift all right what's it
what's a good you know the deserts a
good drifty drift sweet sweet Canyon its
planes of traffic it's a class a car
zagnut planes II exactly plates of
traffic oh man I love knows her stuff
you guys aren't allowed to do like can
you guys ride motorcycles and stuff or
no because you're part of the team
yeah yeah big no-no wow that's crazy is
there like a list of things you got like
skydiving probably not shouldn't be
doing that anyway by the way yeah yeah
now I've never seen a list there's just
it's just kind of common knowledge I
don't mean yeah exactly
not a lot of like not a lot of severe
hot sauces stay away from the upper
echelon
and I think that like habanero and below
note ghost peppers
you can't oh my god oh man I'm already
last we actually used to have a garden
in the whole thing oh is that true and
we had like some of the world's hottest
peppers in there oh my god and somebody
takes for like one day during beat the
one of the okay thank you yeah yeah yeah
took one was passing around the outfield
and like go to take a bite music no no
no like yeah like take less than that
and you just take a little nibble and
I was like sweating eyes were like
watering for at least 30 minutes really
oh my god
as soon as bang crash was over everybody
just won and it just got like all the
milk cartons yeah because I guess like
if you like water won't work on those
like a hot peppers you're like I think
so what we're trying to go like
Gatorades and stuff and literally just
made it worse
oh my god that's insane man I know it's
weird like I I couldn't do spicy for a
long time and then I lost like a ton of
weight you know so it was like eating
super healthy elastic 19 miles and so
it's just like a lot of chicken a
chicken is so boring so I just got me
really into hot sauces and now it's like
I think I like destroyed my tugs now I
just I mean like the only way I could
feel a motion anymore it's like by super
hot sauces and I can't mix crazy sauces
and just like man it's crazy yeah my
apartments like a typical bachelor pad
with like a fridge full of condiments
and nothing else just cuz my hot sauce
and rampage
that's crazy man I know those peppers
but people love that stuff you know it's
crazy some there's some hot sauce this
guy makes where he has to wear a gas
mask to do it dude
really oh god this is a horse talk Oh
ice cream should help signa there we go
I just came helps anything baby well
that's a dairy product yeah there we go
any kind of dairy
what about like cheese I got just spread
cheese on yeah the shirt thank you Ken
appreciate the shirt shout out exactly
spicy food will make you lose lose
weight through one door a moon door if
you don't have a thing exactly i'm saucy
everybody only on that note let's do a
little uh still a sweet sweet canyon i
love it
you guys have any what's your guilty
pleasure food got anything you just
can't you're saying chicken and waffles
or no yeah checking a waffle it's really
good you ever been in Roscoe's no yeah
oh yeah I don't do that one down here I
think it's in LA for sure yeah yeah
there's so many crazy things that I just
although I'm not like a sweet sky I like
salty stuff like Cheetos it's not a joke
I love to you okay I can't like for some
reason I'm just like but that's what's
great about chicken waffles man it's
sweet and it's salty you get everything
it's crunchy its sticky its hit you
can't go wrong I mean the only way to go
wrong is by eating it a lot that's a
problem I'm coming to play today boys
here we go look out baby Mario I did it
this time
my eyes aren't like used to like chaos
like yeah then we have water and then we
or upside down I think they did get a
little I mean the first time I felt old
in my life is when I played this game
for the first time sounds like what is
happening I wonder what we look like
right now people watching basically like
you know like the ones like yeah you
people are like okay yeah yeah that
plays with their body yeah it's a mess
finally I'm gonna beat somebody although
I am at 7-7 here we go
what is something here's actually here's
a legitimate question
what's something that people that would
be surprising to people about playing in
the major leagues like what's something
weird that people wouldn't normally
think of like when you were a kid no and
you can you dreamt about playing
baseball what something you didn't
expect now that you're in now that your
major league growing up like playing
Little League you like show up like 30
minutes before the game you gotta
stretch yeah and like it's like oh yeah
you just show up play catch for a couple
minutes and then you play your game
right yeah and I think a lot of people
don't realize that we show up at like
1:00 o'clock oh my god uh seven o'clock
games oh really
just preparation batting practice
getting your work in getting your
weights in watches so you guys actually
work out before a game yeah it's like a
completed practice before game
really but that I did so don't you get
tired because those games are wrong to
you just do your just got your Easter
routine yeah that's awesome Wow and I
guess it's like it does get you super
focused you know and and plus I when
you're actually playing you've just done
the exact same thing you were doing you
know we're doing it yesterday you're
doing it like an hour ago so it's not
right it kind of puts you in that mental
of mental space that's crazy
do you guys wonder what are some of your
favorite moments so far in your careers
to be bad like memorable other than like
playing you like walking out of the
field for your first your first game um
like an event I guess yeah are just like
a moment that meant a lot to you I
pitched on Mother's Day a couple years
ago whoa my mom came down to watch it
was also a birthday oh that's great
those people that's awesome it yeah
that's got to be really cool to have
like you know to be able to like perform
basically for your parents it's going to
go you know and your friends do all
right I think we got time for one more
game what's the last out was the last
race for playing do rainbow road rainbow
road man today the old school rainbow
rotor then yeah he's won in 64 here we
go absolutely all right get ready all
right guys we're gonna lose Eric Johnson
Robbie Rowland and a few seconds so if
you guys got questions YouTube's killing
it man you guys are just on point today
you're insane oh yeah I know I know
it's luckily it's going by too fast when
you read it exactly but get your
questions in now for Robbie Rowland and
Eric Johnson when you got what do you
guys do during the offseason do you like
to travel
but as you are you both you're both from
California right yeah yeah actually grew
up like oh that's a toe yeah I don't
think we ever played against each other
well did you have you had you met before
where join the Padres no dude small
world
oh yeah that's awesome oh my god I am
gonna come in so last this woman can I
come in
more lasted 12 is that possible they're
gonna add people so I'll be even more or
less there we go yeah there any teams
that you like to play against the most
or fear the most besides your own of
course practice yeah that's true
you guys was to read like before you
guys watch tape and all that stuff right
you're doing a research I think it's
probably people don't really understand
either probably how much homework you
guys have to do yeah you know like it's
not just I got the star oh you guys are
so at yeah you know what screws me up is
there's no railings on rainbow road
rainbow road though put railings on
there it's very dangerous should fall
off into the sky the mushroom is also if
it's how good of a driver you are okay
and as you can see I'm in 12 players
yeah I'm gonna Levitt so I am just the
mushroom is almost a liability on this
she got hit the straightaway
that was quick perfect Wow
dude I beat you at the bottom that's
well there we go perfect oh my god well
guys thank you for joining us guys
awesome
make sure to watch tonight Padres play
the cards at st. Louis so at 5:15 check
your local listings and follow you guys
on social media with your things are you
Instagram Instagram and Twitter it's Rob
here early
yeah I'm off the grid off the grid
unless so the terminators are not gonna
find Ariel when that when the wrote when
Skynet takes over he's gonna be safe the
rest of us are done for so awesome thank
you guys thanks again all right cool
see you later and coming up very quickly
we have a special guest so stay tuned
and it is Ruthie outside what's gonna
happen now I think that's it thanks guys
all right this is great no rehab that we
have it is thanks for playing a real
game Jeff thanks for playing a real game
awesome all right yep cool thank you see
you guys later
thanks oh yeah there we go
follow Robbie and follow Rick that was
awesome those guys are actually real
professional athletes that's pretty
broccoli I think this room has like
guess who's coming oh really
I don't even know if they're gonna show
up so we'll see why don't we switch to
Mario maker what do you say oh people
are asleep we're streaming every day
until yeah yep we'll be streaming every
day with a special guest down here from
comic-con and
[Music]
no software update complete it's gonna
be fun if you can't play this I'm gonna
love this exactly who would win a
baseball bat third bleh
Jedi mastered Elizabeth I think you
would win I cycled slugger on my
softball team
why because I swung a lot and missed did
you ever play t-ball as a kid you guys
remember t-ball where it's like it's
Lydia it's literally yeah it's just like
they put a ball on a pole yeah and then
the kid just hits the ball off the pole
we all made out of like plastic yeah and
it's just like what are we doing we have
knots treated downstream yesterday no
we're we're streaming but we're
streaming every day at 11:00 so here we
go all right so let's make some yeah
yeah we threw out maybe like maybe up
what up upper left any bottom left yeah
oh thank you everyone thank you exactly
we are working oh we should do
periscopes more often we're definitely
gonna be doing a lot of live streaming
down here Facebook live periscope yeah
we got a lot of great guests
all right let's let's make how do I do
this I can't even get this going
good god weak mommy oh so long a lot
missed you need to practice we're
practice makes perfect
I guess perfect practice makes perfect
is what they say great please
and we brought yeah we brought our wall
with us this is a different room yeah a
different City mm-hmm hundreds miles
away this is true hundreds like 200 are
we two two miles away I don't understand
distance words all right oh my god there
we go I think I could do it with I think
I do with this can I do with this all
right let's make a course yeah we
upgraded our playroom cream shooter Oh
big cream in the house we're at
comic-con unisys snapchat is better than
periscope I will say if you're not
following to cook on snapchat you got to
get on that
a lot of good stuff just got the thumbs
up from Gemma because she loves snow a
lot of good snaps I got I got I caught
Jordan yesterday taking a selfie
outside the Spreckels theater it was
wait please put it on that's great
all right let's make a crazy course wait
let's put a budget all right I don't
remember exactly how to do this area all
right uh let's create it guys do you
tell me what you want to see on a Mario
course and I'm gonna make it first of
all how do i erase all of this
no one knows Ron Funches
so I'm Funches who may or may not be
joining us later this week made a lot of
really cool courses and it was awesome
exactly Oh professor professor Fabian
wait isn't this guy fieri I'm confused
I'm Guy Fieri's younger brother Gary
fear in Fieri okay let's see here when
you guys want to see with some more uh I
wonder what this year is called intro
the show is gonna be I don't know four
allowed to say I don't think we're
allowed to say but we do have some great
a guest coming up yeah that's who our
guest we have the Suicide Squad the
whole cast coming tomorrow this for our
first day is all the Silicon Valley
that's right Silicon Valley folks who we
love and Thursday is CW heroes day Bazar
with wings you want to see a Bowser with
wings alright coming up you know Bowser
ooh is that a hammer brother a Bowser
with what is this a Bowser yeah a couple
a couple these mofos it's it's some
wings item
I just look this game is amazing if you
don't have Mario maker it's the best
exactly Middleditch I love middle - he's
the best it's so weird to me cuz
Middleditch to me by the way I hate your
computer it keeps going to sleep
Middleditch he's like one of the
funniest dudes I've ever seen in my life
and he plays the most serious depressed
guy on that show he's like the only guy
actually acting everyone else is kind of
playing themselves like TJ Kumail like I
mean I don't know Martin but I you know
he's pretty chill out of it that's right
yeah it feels yeah that's awesome
that's awesome you system antara
not Mario maker Justin we're doing it
right suck in blocks please I will pay
uses Leena no I won't but you did give
me a good how about I read coke oh wow
does that say cocoa I don't think so for
whatever how do i erase stuff anyone
know over there we go nighttime
underground how do I get rid of stuff
I'll figure it out
don't you worry about me don't you worry
about me y'all
oh god this is just making more blocks
we're in trouble though they're in a
race button who knows about how to erase
stuff close enough this boat in life I
love it
it's super funny that's right that was
cool are those nice if the Padres came
by last year we had whom we have wil
Myers last year yeah Padres are a great
team and bunch of nice folks I'm gonna
starting over how do i how do I start
over here racer on the right racer on
the right they say this oh god what's
this
oh there we go ooh I really like a
racing stuff oh yeah
a big white hand by the way all right
let's do I'm gonna start here we go
we're gonna program Joel let's pull the
goal out a little bit have you seen that
there's this thing online which is very
heart heart-wrenching which is like
about a videogame it says we only go
forward and it's a comic and it's a guy
like he's jumping and he goes he can't
get crop across this jump and then so he
like meets like a girl or whatever and
this whole thing and then they have like
a little family has a little kid and the
kid kind of jumps over and then he can't
go back
yeah middle of switches middle which
actually I just show where he invites
people up to play him against blue
square zero sir
following that mofo right away do it
what are your Twitter handles gray Moon
Team Coco yep Conan O'Brien
yep I'm I'm Aaron blared I think what
are you better ask you what are you what
you will yeah that's what I say when I
make a bad choice um how do i erase that
I do wish service and control Z in my
life you know awesome
Jim Apollo everyone Apollo in the room
what's happening is everything okay oh
this is gonna be fun how do I do see I
don't want to do this all right here he
is ladies and gentlemen
Jordan slansky that's right give it up
give it up for Jordan Jordan playing
Mario maker say hi to the chat Jordan I
was summoned to him he hates this he
hates this will be kind this is all
YouTube here this is all twitch exactly
everyone see you look people love you
Darth butters loves you butters
yeah Andy butts solid willed oh one
petrol CK oh my god you gotta do lux any
months exactly there we go oh my god the
secret everybody's freaking out and
what's clapping perfect that's right you
guys asked Jordan your questions now you
have a chance this is a very limited
chance it's only because we're down here
at comic-con that Jordan was forced to
come yeah he was I think he's gonna be
paid cash money later you have a lot of
fans no one knows why I think people do
that why I think people know what Jordan
is hilarious it's great
are you real somebody asked I think so
he thinks he's really things an illusion
like in the matrix I believe that I'm
real see you think I don't you guys
don't understand that Jordan is actually
this is how he is this is just him this
is live this isn't edited this is just
what is what are you wearing Jordan
you're wearing I mean assure them pants
yeah I mean these are typical
conventions that were particularly
original here
typical conventions pioneered hundreds
of years ago I said sure to pants he
said typical conventions pioneered
hundreds of years ago oh my god you keep
a room that I Jeff Vader in it I don't
know who Jeff Vader is Jordan
livestreaming 2016 what a year
all right we're playing have you played
a new Mario do you like Mario no I used
to play Super Mario Brothers occasional
I believe a bar is originally a
character from Donkey Kong he had a
brother who need you oh yeah he did yeah
that's true
Wow it was a successful spin-off I don't
know much about video games that I would
venture to guess or it was one of the
more successful than your game spin-offs
in the history of the media nam free nam
ask can you rate the last Star Wars one
to ten I thought I thought the last Star
Wars was a satisfying
okay what satis what do you mean
satisfying you that means you liked it I
enjoyed my experience you enjoyed your
experience you could just say you liked
it you don't have to just say do you
down in San Diego's more wet wipes less
wet wipes are about the same well
actually one would say fewer wet wipes
right because less is when you're not
talking about a specific quantity if
your aspects got a quantity of life yeah
the correct word should be fewer and
that's solid Willard also sorry to have
Shane jr. but also that would also mean
like of each wet wipe do you use less
surface area of each wet wipe
rather right that would be I would
rather you in car you since I would
think that's consistent yeah okay
Oh Jordan what are you expecting for
road why that new road one knew that I
was excited about based on the trailer
that is there we go very exciting I like
her yeah I like the concept of including
little-known actors and restarting fresh
that's right
you haven't you you've only missed about
15 minutes or 10 minutes of Jordan I
when Jordan steps in the room it's hard
to really time kind of gets a little
wonky it's like being close to like a
like a black hole you're talking about I
don't know if in a general I I'm not
exactly sure I'm not exactly sure what's
happening I think it's all I'm hearing
now there's like a like a ice cream
headache in my head you can't get it's
like being close to high power lines
when you're near Jordan he you am it a
field around you have you walked around
comic-con ER are you planning on walking
here I hope that I get a chance to make
it onto the convention crew you know
what I'm really fascinated about
regarding this whole process yes is the
international component that's present
yeah never guess yeah that some of these
people are from all over the world I'm
always curious we're sitting here in a
hot sweaty
it is hot sore disgusting room and I'm
curious how far are reaches how far do
we go yeah everybody Jordan wants to
know it sound off what country you are
posting from that's right
[Music]
this is a world captain quit
oh here's a good question Jordan would
you download your mind into a robot body
to live longer no you wouldn't would you
interested in ceding destiny really you
wouldn't want to freeze your brain I'm
happy with the way humanity is evolved
Wow Wow oh wow oh yeah Malaysia Belgium
India Philippines Russia Estonia and
Antarctica that's impossible France I
will be enduring it next month I'm
particularly interested to see what your
Austria I may actually go into Austria
worse I know you love traveling to Italy
obviously I do like Italy a lot where
was it what was the first time you went
to Italy what we were feeling today
strike you immediately or has your love
for Italy grown as you have traveled
there more often first I went to Italy
was April 1999 and why wouldn't that
trip changed my life I don't really need
to be melodramatic but I believe it's
true is there a specific moment where
you were like this is it or when you got
back to the trip you or the whole trip
was just wave after wave of joy now that
you asked there was a specific moment
okay and while it may not sound like
much I think the effect was profound it
was a moment in one particular
restaurant where I tasted a particular
tomato sauce that was like nothing I'd
ever tasted before it's a tomato sauce
yes and it opened my mind to the fact
that there could be other components of
food wine and life are like nothing I've
ever experienced before and it really
inspired in me a quest to grow as a
person oh my god that's crazy and as a
cultural citizen of the world so it was
a tomato sauce Jordan do you do juice
cleanses I don't I don't believe in
juice - see the problem is you're
removing the fiber when you're talking
about a fruit or a vegetable you're
talking about nature's perfect food the
whole food if you will there's a balance
of sugar but also fiber in there now
that sugar is not going to be released
into the blood all at once because the
fiber is going to slow down the release
of sugar into a steady stream the
problem is when you artificially take
that fiber out and present a juice now
you're talking about sugar without the
fiber to slow it down that sugar goes
into your blood all at once and your
buddy your body detects a spiking your
blood sugar so now to remedy that your
body secretes insulin who has it
somebody your pancreas and that insulin
takes the sugar out of your blood and
stores it for later because the body is
a very efficient being it stores it for
later as fat problem there is your blood
sugar that is raw and creates a response
where you want more sugar geez so when
you're taking a whole food like apple
for example now one apple has 5 grams of
fiber
I hope this dream never ends oh my god
but when you're taking that and you're
removing the fiber in a way that nature
never intended you're you're feeding
your body something that it was not
meant to digest who asked that question
shame on you
here's an easier question Superman or
Batman somebody asks Superman super why
specifically 1978 Richard Wow first one
Christopher Reeves the very first
Christmas uber not only do I believe
that the 1978 Richard Donner Superman is
my clear at superhero movie I would say
it's my favorite movie of all time the
first hour of that movie is pure
perfection I'm not talking about the
director's cut when it was re-released
on DVD in 2000 they felt the need to add
footage as a marketing point they say
Richard Donner approves the footage god
damn it I feel like he would have
approved anything at that big given the
right context but I'm telling you that
the theatrical cut the first hour is
incredibly moving and you know what most
of it has nothing to do with superheroes
at all
just on an emotion level and the score
by John Williams is my favorite John
Williams score better than Star Wars as
well that is a good tip well that
service yeah now that score was
originally released as a double LP in
1978 when it was released on CD in 1990
they removed sweet grass growing up in
lex luthor's layer because it needed to
fit on a single disc although the
Japanese version had the entire track
listing cut to the year 2000 when a
gentleman named Mike Madison
produced a CD re-release which was now a
to gist of the entire score it was
mastered a little loud for my taste and
somewhat brick walls but the sound was
great 2008 film score Monthly Magazine
released a box set of all the Superman
movies again it wasn't a big fan of the
mastering on that so I do feel like the
Superman soundtrack is yet to see its
greatest rerelease so when I asked
Superman or Batman
hey buddy be Superman I understand that
we're here in honor of Comic Con and
this is the perfect venue to discuss
these matters that's true that is a long
answer for Superman or Batman but
respect a true answer and one that I
agree with and also Richard Donner
Superman is amazing unbelievable I don't
know what they're doing with the new
Superman movies it's crazy it's too dark
it's insane I don't know what they're
doing I hope Superman like Superman -
well Superman - is an interesting
circumstance because half of it was
directed by George Honor and was shot
simultaneously with the original wait is
that yours yeah he was fired by the
salkinds
Alexander and Ilyas sell times they were
their producers of the movie he was
fired halfway through and they're
replacing with a director named Richard
Lester half the scenes were shot by
Richard Lester and they have a
completely different tones than the
Richard Donner seeking soul it's almost
as if half of that movie is great and
half of it isn't and those halves are
not necessarily chronological what so
it's really two movies by two different
directors it's one movie it's like three
different directors it's what yeah it's
the hard day's night of Superman movies
if you're watching this stream pay no
attention to what I'm doing with the
blocks send help if you have any other
questions Jordan has to go in about five
minutes so if you have any other
questions now is your chance to ask
Jordan slansky by the way follow Jordan
on Instagram at Jordan slansky on
snapchat you're on snapchat now at just
at Jordan slansky
yes all of your handles are just Jordan
slansky
I will tell you that I learned that
the amount of characters in my full name
or the maximum that snapchat allows for
a username Wow
had I not been able to fit my whole name
I would have had to get creative come up
with something clever would you have the
easy way out I kind of figure you know
what I actually I I will beg to differ
with you I would say you probably
wouldn't have joined snapchat if you
couldn't fit your whole name in there
Jordan slants you can't do that the real
Jordan you're not gonna do that that's
that's crap but ideally one would get
their full man ideally one would get
their full name that's true that's you
that's not my mode of self-expression
that's racial media handles do you watch
Doctor Who I do not I respect it I
remember as a kid the old series was
always on shot on video yeah very
particular look to it very particularly
I didn't like the aesthetics of it at
the time but I understand it's a very
well respected series I will learn one
more one hour of hanging with Jordan
that I haven't my 19 year old life so
far that's true that is out to Romania
Nessie there is somebody that is right
in his handle and I respect that general
Jin mania what do you like to see in an
Internet handle what do you like to see
is it okay to have numbers it's okay to
name yourself like Jango Fett like after
a character or no you should be more
yourself do you have any views on how
didhow them what it would be the proper
way the Jordan shlonsky way to come up
with an Internet handle do you have any
tips my value artistic expression okay
I'm not your judge nor should any okay
how someone chooses to express their
artistic instance whether it's by a
hammer other good I can only tell you
what I prefer for myself oh my god I do
see a lot of science fiction references
coming up on the screen and I always
appreciate that's right that's right you
know one thing if you follow Jordan on
Instagram at Georgia slansky what you
should one thing you'll see is Jordan
really likes ice cream now this is
something I didn't realize I live very
close to in Los Angeles a place called
Jenny's ice cream and I was wearing a
shirt one day and Jordan commented on my
Jenny as ice cream shirt and Jenny's is
one of your favorites well it's
interesting Jenny's it's one of the few
ice cream makers that uses grass-fed
milk their cream is not grass but I may
say well why is grass-fed dairy
important of course cows were
Nature has evolved cows to feed on grass
and it's a disturbance between the dairy
from grass-fed cattle and grain fed
cattle is that the fat content in either
in both the meat and the milk is
completely different it hasn't really
make it three fatty acids instead of
omega-6 omega-9 people make a an attempt
to eat more omega-3 fatty acids such as
fish oil
it also has CLA it also has beta
carotene which appears in the grass
sometimes grass-fed milk almost has a
yellow hue to it oh my god real and
that's just that's literally because
what they eat it's that job they're
supposed to eat of course cows will
people will eat anything that's put in
front of them yes most animals will
however including human beings including
me however however grass of course is
what cows were designed by nature to
George so so when it comes ice cream do
you what flavours like someone is asking
chocolate or vanilla depends on what I'm
eating it with you want contrast you
were having a warm chocolate cake you
clearly want the vanilla ice cream there
we go
and vice versa but overall I would have
to go with the childhood favorite of
mint chocolate chip make chocolate chip
and these are a specific brand you like
the best of mint chocolate chip right
now my favorite mint chocolate chip is
to Lent each a lot of RAM you can tell
the supermarket's they're out of Dallas
most of the till NZ flavors are a little
sweet for me I think they really nailed
it mint chocolate chip the great thing
about cilenti is their texture is very
light and accurate now real gelato is
supposed to be stored at a slightly
higher temperature than most American
freezers in most ice cream is why is
that because it creates a softer texture
however it's not practical for most
Americans to have a separate gelato
freezer so everything goes in the main
freezer and therefore most gelato gelato
from a real gelateria food in your
freezer would get so hard
remember tell empty as final has found a
way to achieve the correct texture even
in the colder american freezer
environment oh my god so right now
ttle NC mint chocolate chip is gelato is
your favorite is my favorite mint
chocolate chip and me my favorite
cilenti flea
same time I generally find that most
friends have one flavor that they excel
it for example a lot of Fiasco there out
of Maine they have a great grass-fed or
green fed they are they don't advertise
which leads me to believe it's great
grain fed cows are partially grass-fed
oh I'm but finished with grain
especially for me because it creates a
battery or environment God there was a
gentleman from Texas made appreciatively
finished with however there's a lot of
Fiasco flavor I like espresso chip I
think they really nailed that wow he's
such a rip yeah he's real if you think
Jordan is not real this is your proof
that he's real this is live we're not I
should hold up in today's newspaper
this is not pre-taped exactly omid
chocolate chip is Jed turnouts flavor -
you're just saying that turnout you're
just saying that
exactly all right one more question for
jordan then he has to go I wonder if
this will make it on the show this is
this we could play this this could be
the entire show Jordan could be the
entire show and probably in two years
Jordan will be the entire exactly you
know on must says we're all players in a
giant video game do you agree or
disagree with that Jordan well this is
very similar to the concept of the
aforementioned matrix that's what you
ask if I'm real I'm only as real as I
think I am wait you're only as real as
you think you are that's true is there
any way to prove to ourselves that we
are or are not in a futuristic computer
simulation but run by some kind of
evolved life form that's not human and
then the bigger question is do we need
to know that information that you know
what that's the question that no
scientists actually asked do we even
need to know before I leave I want to
point out that Erin Blair and I have
these conversations that's true very
often this is John any cameras usually
in my office this is true maybe once
every few weeks but when you do come in
and we do talk we get it all that we
have these conversations and there's
another gentleman on staff Chris Hayes
there's faces into it as well
responsible really for the all the
internet connection and all the
electronic wizardry that's allowed us to
broadcast like this all over the world
exactly which are now how conversations
where we will actually draw out like
comics have been drawn not comics but I
tried to draw in my haircut that I got
one time and other things with a pencil
remember that have people seen old
pictures of you because they are looking
to create some entertainment I know
Aaron blared since I'm gonna say around
2000 oh yeah 2001 and that's right and
see pictures of how he's evolved over a
few years it's crazy not necessarily to
eat grass but evolved quite romantic
that's nevertheless I think that's
that's a good half-hour of entertain
Jordan was the reason I got to go on the
last West mr. dog remote he was a person
who he sent me on that remote with
Roberts Michael is awesome alright one
last question is Jordan what are your
just thoughts on pokemons go just
general general thoughts across the
board Pokemon go unfortunately I'm not
familiar with it however from the
limited data that I do know yes I do
think it's always a good thing when
video games move off of the couch and
into the real world there we go
Jordan is a fan of Pokemon go you heard
it here first all right well thank you
Jordan for stopping by
follow Jordan Jordan slam scan Instagram
and snapchat of course in Torreon
twitter twitter also is jordan shlonsky
anything out those are the things you're
not only triumph the holy trial all
right Thank You Jordan thank you say
goodbye to Jordan everybody awesome and
thank you all for joining joining us for
this our first inaugural comic-con
stream koko we will be streaming from
comic-con every day from 11 to noon from
this beautiful room in the bowels of the
Spreckels theater make sure to watch
Conan starting tomorrow at 11:00 10:00
central on TBS for our amazing comic-con
shows we're gonna have a crazy lineup
this week including the cast of Silicon
Valley
the cast of Suicide Squad cast of Game
of Thrones the cast of Golden Girls just
kidding that was a fake one I know Beth
got super excited obvious it's gonna be
an amazing week with a lot of insane
comedy and now I'm gonna go downstairs
and watch rehearsal thank you all for
joining us thank you again to Robby
Ireland and Eric Jobs of the San Diego
Padres
we're stopping by today and we will see
you guys tomorrow at 11:00 see you guys
later
[Music]
you